also remind you if you ever shop on
amazon.com the shopping you do can
support the work that we do if you first
go to david pakman.com slash membership
a lot of people streaming the second
season of mr. robot over the last week
uh producer Jason Shepherd is now
completely caught up on mr. robot now I
want you to tell me the truth when I
recommended to you a show that was on on
USA you had some skepticism didn't you I
was very skeptical you told me that just
let you know the thing everyone said
it's on USA I have never seen a good us
a show since maybe the eighties when I
was eight years old about anything was
good uh a lot of people in our audience
also jumping on the mr. robot bandwagon
I'm completely up to date except on last
wednesday's show which i do plan to
watch tonight i've been told that it is
a doozy uh and don't say anything more
about that because i don't i don't want
to spoil it for me it's riddled with
okay right also a lot of people from our
audience using our amazon link to buy
season one of Rick and Morty I have some
friends that are obsessed with Rick and
Morty I saw one episode I did kind of
find it funny but it didn't suck me in
where I had any curiosity to keep on
going I don't know if it's a show you
watch uh haven't been watching
religiously up seen a few episodes its
kind of along the lines of ren and
stimpy bad a very slapstick off the wall
very interesting but I used to like Ren
and Stimpy uh I just love that show
hilarious I think thing my parents
didn't like me watching it actually turn
me off but anyways I remember it being
pretty I mean by modern standards I can
imagine as a parent being too worried
about renan Stimpy but maybe at the time
it was considered somewhat shocking yeah
that was the law you know when beavis
and butthead and all these other shows
yet starting to break into the
mainstream in so comparatively uh may be
disturbing to some parents at the time
if you ever shop on amazon david
pakman.com slash amazon is the place to
go to support the work that we do